hey everyone its Johanna here you know
we see the Victoria's Secret models
walking down the runway and they look
absolutely fit and toned they are
definitely not skinny but fit and turn
so does it come down to only good
genetics or do they actually have a
really good meal plan and exercise plan
to go along with it well to look that
thin and tone and to have such a nice
ass it's definitely your genetics what I
want to share with you today are some of
the models favorite ingredients some of
their favourite meals and snacks that
they like to have which will give them
lots of energy for the busy day ahead
yet at the same time is full of protein
and low in calories this is based on a
1200 calories meal plan which is low in
carbs and high in protein which is
really good to help you to lose weight
and tone up it might sound low in
calories but by using clean unprocessed
and natural ingredients these meals will
actually fill you up keep you out of
hunger and it would give you the energy
you need for a busy day ahead so what do
these angels actually have for breakfast
so let's start with breakfast the most
important meal to kick-start our
metabolic rates all of us should have
our breakfast within one hour of us
waking up in order to kick-start our
metabolic rate and for our body to start
burning fat
so choose a protein packed breakfast to
fill you up and to get you ready for the
rest of the day what I have here is an
eggy oat meal so instead of your usual
oatmeal what I've added here is an egg
to increase your protein intake this
oatmeal is really easy and really quick
to me what you need is 40 grams of
oatmeal 1 large egg 1/2 a medium banana
sliced about 200 ml of water and you may
also add a quarter teaspoon of cinnamon
if you like cinnamon or even vanilla
essence so the first step is to cook
your own meal with water under a slow
heat while that's cooking whisk your one
egg and just mesh your banana with a
fork
once your oatmeal is about to cook add
your mashed banana into the onion
mixture and just constantly stir it and
add your egg and keep stirring it until
all the ingredients are mixed well and
you will have a medium thick eggy
oatmeal mixture there you have it your
Eddy oatmeal I know most of us I'm not
used to any ate into our mixture but you
will barely taste the egg instead what
you're getting is also the sweetness
from your banana and I've topped it up
with a little bit of berries just to
make it look nice this breakfast only
contains two hundred seventy eight point
five calories and you're getting 13.8
gram of protein in your breakfast to
kickstart your day if you have the time
what you can do
is to add half a teaspoon of baking
powder into your oatmeal mixture and
just cook it under a hot grill to make
oatmeal pancakes which is something I
like to do over the weekends to
accompany your breakfast what I have
here is a glass of green tea green tea
has been proven to increase your
metabolic rate
most of the villa's models would have
green tea throughout the day and its
really good to your tummies so if want
to have a flat tummy drink green tea
instead of other hot drinks and have 2
to 3 cups per day so the models are
always really busy if they are always
going for one shoot to the next shoot
and at the same time they have to keep
their energy level high therefore for
their snack it has to be something
really simple
something really portable and something
really easy to eat what I have here is a
selection of food to keep your energy
level high to keep you out of hunger at
the same time to keep you at the top of
your performance level so this is about
25 gram of cashew nuts you can always
change it for other nuts that you prefer
about 100 gram of grapes same thing you
can always opt for another fruit and
about 125 gram of Greek yogurt the
models love Greek yogurt because it's
low in calories is high in protein and
it will keep you satisfied so you can
choose to pack this into your snack box
you can always buy a small pot of yogurt
which is more convenient or
alternatively you can mix them all
together and have them in a bowl so be
wise and choose a healthy snack option
which is high in protein and filled with
healthy fats this will keep you
satisfied keep your out of hunger give
you lots of energy to keep you going
through the day and at the same time to
reduce your craving and to avoid
mindless my drink
as for lunch because it's in the middle
of the day it's got to be a huge portion
something really quick and easy that
doesn't require cooking and it can be
put together in under five minutes so
what I have here is a large ball of
grilled chicken salad all this
ingredients here can be bought ready and
can be eaten immediately so it's really
easy and convenient for the models and
for those of you who are busy the
ingredients you'll need are Instagram of
lettuce 100 gram of baby carrots 1
medium tomato sliced which is also about
100 grand three ounces of grilled
chicken which is about 85 gram 1 TSP of
olive oil and just half of a small lemon
or quarter of a large lemon for the
dressings all I'm doing here is to put
all the ingredients into a large bowl or
you can put it into your lunchbox to
bring it out with you to make the salad
dressing mix 1 teaspoon of olive oil
with your lemon juice mix it all and
just drizzle it all over your salad
guess how many calories is in this large
bowl of salad only 202 calories it is
extremely low or packed full of protein
from your chicken you are getting 25
grams of protein for me chicken and also
your healthy carbs and low carbs from
the variety of vegetables feel free to
help yourself to as much vegetables fc-1
especially lettuce because it's
considered a free food this amount of
letters only contain 12 calories that's
how low it is
but they will all fill you up and top
this setting up with your healthy fat
which is from your olive oil olive oil
is really good for your hair and skin
which is important for the models to
live gradient on the runway have this
bowl of salad for lunch and
company is with another cup of green tea
the Angels love to have fairies as part
of their daily meal strawberries
raspberries blueberries are packed full
of natural sugar and it's filled with
antioxidant which helps them to be
healthy and give them the glowing look
so your next snack is a barrel Isha's
dessert which is made from silken tofu
tofu is a really great source of protein
it's low in calories and it's suitable
for vegan as well the ingredients you
need to make this pair religious dessert
are 150 grams of silken tofu 150 grams
of mixed berries and just about 50 ml of
water there is only one step to this
bear Alicia's dessert mix all your
ingredients into a blender and blend it
up what you'll have is a thick mixture
pour your mixture into a wine glass or
even your snack box and allow it to
chill in the fridge for one hour until
it's firm and this is your berry lishus
dessert it's packed full of antioxidants
which would give you the glowing look
packed full of protein you are getting
10.5 gram of protein and the best part
is it only has one hundred and thirty
six point five calories I've also added
a little bit of greater dark chocolate
you can opt out if you want to start
adding berries into your daily diet and
you will have a glowing and radiant look
so you just got back from work or school
you had a long day you're extremely
tired and you feel like having a
takeaway for dinner
don't the next recipe I'm going to show
you it's really quick it's really simple
quicker than your takeaways and
definitely much healthier than your
takeaways the models loved salmon salmon
is considered a superfood it's packed
full of healthy fat which is your
omega-3 fatty acid it's much low in
calories and it will fill you up to make
this salmon spinach frittata the
ingredients you need are two salmon
fillet which is about three ounces each
150 gram of frozen spinach 150 gram of
broccoli two large eggs and 30 gram of
grated cheese the first step is to place
a salmon fillet into the pan and allow
it to simmer I am NOT going to add any
extra oil because you are already
getting the healthy oil from your salmon
just break and stab it into pieces and
once the salmon is cooked add the frozen
spinach and frozen broccoli into your
pan and just allow all the ingredients
to simmer I'll be adding a little bit of
vegetable stock just for the extra
flavor you can always use chicken stock
if you want to once the salmon and
vegetables are cooked place them into an
ovenproof train break two eggs and whisk
it I like to add a little bit of water
because it cooks better and just pour
your egg in and cover it evenly and top
it up with your grated cheese now all
you need to do is to put this into the
oven for 10
fifteen minutes until your egg mixture
is solid so this is your protein packet
dinner which is a great way to end the
day you are getting lots of protein from
a salmon I've chosen spinach and
broccoli because they are much higher in
protein in comparison to other
vegetables extra protein from your eggs
as well and also more protein and
healthy fat from your grated cheese this
one serving only has 270 2.3 calories
and you're getting thirty six point
seven gram of protein probate at the
moment this is my favorite dinner
and it is really great especially when
you've just done your workout session so
try it out so this is my Victoria's
Secret Angels meal plan it will help you
to lose weight lean up and to lose your
stubborn belly fat the total calories is
one thousand two hundred and four
calories and you are getting 31.5% of
protein from the total calories for more
high protein low carb food and
substitutes for vegan please visit this
website because they have got a really
comprehensive list of high protein low
carb foods which you can change and use
in your meal plan you have to drink lots
of water with this meal plan at least
three liters of water a day and opt for
green tea and also do your workout at
least three times a week for best
results to your cup five times a week
if you stick to this meal plan give
yourself one cheat meal a week in
moderation and do your workout there is
no reason why
using the weight the key is to start and
you have to have to be committed be
dedicated be consistent and stick by
your plan until you have achieved your
goal and even after you have achieved
your goal I want this to be your
lifestyle to maintain your weight for
life I really hope this is inspired you
to start your weight loss journey you
can pair this meal pan up together with
my full meal plan video therefore you
can do this meal plan for three days and
my full meal plan for four days please
do visit my website Drona SOCOM to get
the full bill plan and to get the full
workout plan for your 90 days weight
loss challenge to a new you so let's
start now no more excuses and I want you
to see a new you by 2014 for new fitness
food and motivational videos please like
share and subscribe to my You Tube
channel and website do follow me on
Facebook Instagram and Twitter to stay
connected with me thanks guys
you